our prime minister yeah
great to see you yeah thank you
and i i you need more women in positions
of power
if putin was a woman
which i he obviously isn't but if he
were
i really don't think he would have
embarked on a crazy macho war of in
great of invasion and violence in the
way that he has if you want a perfect
example of toxic masculinity it's it
it's what he's doing in ukraine
i think that
it's not going to be easy i'm not going
to pretend that this can be done
quickly but i think what was so striking
from the conversations
is that people really do want to give
the ukrainians strategic endurance
and
i think what everybody agrees is
they want to give him
the ukrainian government we can't be
more ukrainian than the ukrainian right
you know it's the new it's for them to
decide
but they want to help
zelinski to get in the best possible
position to
to talk if and when talks eventually
come
and so that's the strategy right now
about prime minister
deutschland
and you know
there is always going to be lots of
opinions about that and i'm i'm just
going to say that
uh the faster
it recedes behind us in the in in the
universe we leave we leave that uh event
behind us the better and actually
i think uh the the mood is really
changing in a more positive way thank
you much for being with us great thank
you thank you
love to see you bye bye bye everybody
good good the giftful